[Música]
hoy quiero compartir una historia de
familia de vida que hemos pasado durante
ya casi 62 años
una historia que inicia mi padre con una
camioneta un par de mulas una esposa y
cuatro hijos y así llegó aquí
aguascalientes
llegó el agricultor
y para él y ahora para nosotros los
hijos la segunda generación y la tercera
generación que está integrando ya lo más
importante que tenemos en la compañía es
el factor humano las personas que forman
la compañía nosotros le llamamos la gran
familia y así es como hemos ido
avanzando a través de los años y les
quiero platicar dos o tres puntos de
inflexión de la compañía donde ha sido
crítico el factor humano y en la forma
como se ha ido desarrollando está en la
compañía hoy día somos dos mil empleados
tenemos
bisnietos ya trabajando con nosotros
la razón
empezó realmente con 8 empleados les
pagaban
aquí el salario mínimo en ese entonces
era 4 pesos él llegó pagando 8 pesos
la persona que le rentó el rancho todos
lo conocen allí están los huevos cris
ahora ese rancho le dijeron el dueño le
dijo te lo voy a rentar pero te voy a
hacer una aclaración aquí todos los
empleados son muy flojos entonces se
puso a investigar y entonces lo que
pasaba es que les pagaban les pagaba 2
es entonces por esto puede ser mi flor
es un equipo un súper equipo de esas
ocho personas y terminando las jornadas
se salía con ellos
45 de la tarde abajo del mezquita que
había fuera de los corrales donde mulas
y supongamos segarra con ellos siempre
es el cigarro en el tiempo que duraba la
junta entre ellos de platicar que habían
hecho bien
pasan los años va creciendo el negocio
creciendo la familia de los empleados
pero llega un momento donde el clima nos
fastidio todas las cosechas durante dos
años seguidos
entonces ya no pudo seguir el banco y le
dijo ya no te puedo prestar más
en este pagar qué vas a hacer
la casa donde vivíamos aquí en los
bosques vivía en la planta baja y él
estaba en la planta de el segundo piso y
hoy que estaba trabajando para el 34 de
la mañana de subir
jose que ya perdimos todo todo perdimos
estaba el esperado momento y qué
opciones hay estaba saliendo de la prepa
me dicen mira tengo 33 opciones
la primera es pelear me agarra un equipo
de abogados y pelear mediador cuantos
años gramos la segunda
quitar a todos los empleados vender la
maquinaria y aguantarme con esta tierra
que en unos años va a valer mucho dinero
porque está la universidad del club
campestre todo alrededor bien desarrollo
muy fuerte y global de austri nar y la
tercera es vender el terreno pagarle a
la gente a los bancos y llevarme mi
equipo
y mi maquinaria a otro lado y eso hizo
se fue a rentar ya empezar otra vez y
decidió y cómo hacer para iniciar y se
mira cuando inicien no tenía ni yo sabía
la voz por lo redondo de agricultor y
mis empleados tampoco ahora ya todos
sabemos que estamos haciendo y le vamos
a hacer muy bien
se van bastante bien y va creciendo
luego se integra y ahora la segunda
generación cuando entran dos de mis
hermanos y yo regreso de la universidad
también y empezamos a trabajar ya la la
parte industrial
y
dentro de esta primera etapa viene un
empleado que fue muy característico de
esa primera etapa a pedir el trabajo y
le dice y de trabajo
todos ya mañana
el concepto
y empieza hasta muchacho que era muy muy
inteligente
a subir no sabía leer y escribir no
sabía manejar hasta empieza a crecer y
llega a ser literalmente el brazo
derecho de mi padre
lo enseña a leer y escribir lo enseña
manejar cuando aprende a manejar le
choca su camioneta
no le dijo nada era una camioneta naves
y tal acaba de comprar no le dijo una
sola palabra dijo es que no te ha
enseñado bien
y sigue que decía no pasa el tiempo este
muchacho pues ya se imagina en el brazo
derecho era un súper brazo
llega un día que se pelea con un
empleado lo golpea entonces el empleado
se queda callado no dice nada pero pasan
los días mi padre
empezó a investigar hasta que llega x lo
sé
y al llegar
ya llega el mayordomo
el gerente llantos era gerente del
rancho
dice que pasado perdí la cabeza
y de golpe así que vamos a hacer se
ampliase y hasta lo que vamos a hacer es
despedir y aquí grabamos
esto era como las 2 de la tarde a las 6
de la tarde seguían sentados abajo de
mesquite platicando a todos
él sabía que lo tenía que recorrer
la picaban de todas las historias que
habían vivido juntos
recordando el trabajo
en la compañía tenemos dos cosas que no
no podemos pensar
los valores que no podemos romper uno es
la honestidad
y otros el respeto hacia los demás
y eso se lo sabía entonces lo que tú
cuando cumplimos ya 50 años de la
compañía hablamos para el 3t de los
empleados
y dijo que le voy a invitar lo corrimos
pero era buen buen tipo
fui por él a su casa y si voy y estuve
en la fiesta con nosotros mi animal no
paraba de llorar toda la fiesta
estuvieran
ya grande el murió al siguiente año pero
lo sentimos como
a pesar de que hayan corrido a pesar
este órgano pasaba en seguida muy unido
a la compañía de familia de santiago lo
querían el siguió
otro caso muy importante que vayan fue
muy crítico al parecer esta familia es
el momento en que mueren mi hermano
jorge y mi papá en un accidente aéreo
para ubicarlos un poquito estamos
hablando de 1995
acaba de pasar el 94 salidas salinas
entraba el rodillo el país estaba
quebrado en bancarrota los bancos me
decían oye pagan y yo sé pero si todavía
no se vence no le hace tu paga media no
estamos quebrados bueno no te puedo
pagar entonces y fue un tiempo de estira
y afloja en ese en junio mueren ellos
dos
teníamos cuatro compañías que querían
comprarnos la compañía literalmente
estaba en bancarrota en bancarrota todo
lo que debíamos lo diríamos en dólares y
en una de las misas del sepelio se
acercan todos los gerentes y los
directores y me dicen oye que sí que lo
que veamos entre todos les estamos
quebrado
dice que algunos de ellos me dijeron
sabes que estamos listos para seguir
vamos a iniciar otra vez
pero estamos mal dice no le hace
pagarnos la mitad del sueldo a todos
pero todos vamos a trabajar
y así decimos los primeros meses después
del regreso pero fue creciendo otra vez
la compañía poquito a poquito y salió
adelante toda otra vez gracias al
capital humano a las personas
realmente en la compañía o en cualquier
negocio los fierros los edificios y todo
que van y vienen para las personas que
realmente lo que valen
después decimos algunos
programas que han sido muy exitosos
todavía mi padre cuando nos dimos cuenta
que los niños en sexto de primaria los
papás los sacaban de la escuela
bueno qué pasó por qué lo sacaste no es
que mire yo tengo 3º de primaria
ella tiene sexto y aparte no tengo para
comprarle ya siguen los otros chiquillos
no tengo para comprarle algo de más
entonces tenemos un programa para todos
los niños que tuvieran de 85 para arriba
pudieran recibir una beca bueno van
becados primaria secundaria de
universidad y si quieren estudiar alguna
maestría siguen pecados por mandar a
algunos a europa a otros estados unidos
y han crecido junto con la compañía si
ustedes ven habitan el nivel d
el organigrama los primeros cuatro
niveles más del 40 por ciento de esos
cuatro niveles
son muchachos que viven de esos
programas
han sido muy muy exitosas y ahora nos
sorprendió más porque de repente
llegaron muchos niños y nos decían oye
yo también quiero algo pero tú no eres
hijo de un trabajador es el nieto y el
pri marinos no te puedo pecar a todos
entonces se juntaron los empleados los
que ya habían venido ya que venían de
este programa y ellos están pecando a
estos niños ahorita tienen más de 200
niños becados por los trabajadores ellos
mismo están becados nos funciona poco a
poquito el primer esa semillita en cada
una y que luego prosperen ha sido un
éxito si nosotros plan para que
construyan sus casas se juntan entre
ellas se ayudan auto construyen
consiguen materiales
la empresa se expresan ahora son
préstamos no se los regala se les presta
sin intereses pero lo tienen que pagar
vamos a tirar con la casa número 82
entre ellos están cooperando a
construirlo eso me ha gustado mucho otro
problema que teníamos también en las
vacaciones los niños
salían no tenían clases al día nada a
traer el lonche del papá que se venían a
ver van del trabajador el papá pero
venían haciendo de hablar en medio todo
el todo el ranchón regla resorte era y
todos un día para pararon la planta
porque con la resortera le dieron a un
aislador de esta atención se cayó el
cable
ahora la planta
y organizamos un curso de verano para
los niños el año pasado fueron 800 niños
al curso de verano y están en cuatro
semanas y están entrenando y se
divierten ya se acabaron los problemas
de las arterias y una vez
firmas también tenemos nuestra selección
de fútbol y béisbol en varias categorías
están ha sido muy muy exitoso y así al
paso del tiempo les reitero siempre
les digo que como escultor
la semillita que siembras en una persona
siempre siempre vas a cosechar más de lo
que siempre es una vez y esta plática en
una universidad y me decían a oye pues
no tienes personas que le das la mano y
te agarran el pie
y así si hay pero no por esas medio por
ciento 1 por ciento va a destruir todos
los programas que ya estás haciendo no
cuentan ellos no cuenta en la tarde o
temprano se van a dar a regresar
hay un caso que me gusta mucho platicar
de una chica que me habló por teléfono
en la madrugada del sábado así tenemos
vamos camino a monterrey nos
accidentamos mi esposo está la pierna
rota y estamos acá entre saltillo y
monterrey pero qué quieres que haga no
nos puede hacer nada de bab le de la
ambulancia de la cruz roja
ya estamos acá en seguro social pero te
quieren cortar la pierna a mi esposa y
yo no quiero que se la corte
pero yo no soy médico déjame hablar de
la doctora de la compañía estudiaba el
acompañar al hospital y me dice yo sé es
que no está trabajando el aparato para
sentir si la pierna tiene circulación o
no voy a conseguir uno y te avisa
después me habló no y lo conseguimos y
parece que nomás le van a quitar dos
dedos y hasta mucho mejor era diabético
el señor mente estaba con problema como
al mes ahora sí me habla la chica de 16
que ya está en mi casa está muy bien de
hoy cómo te fue
no le cortaron ni las uñas de
exactamente
entonces realmente a veces te cuesta tan
poquito ayudar a alguien y a la otra
persona le cambia la vida
literalmente le cambia la vida no me
quiero imaginar este muchacho sin pierna
porque estaba para el aparatos compuesta
son cosas que poco a poquito vas
aprendiendo y vas allá pero lo que más
nos ha gustado es como saber contagiarlo
a los demás tenemos un programa para los
muchachos del secundario con las becas
que damos en prepa y en mi universidad
donde ellos tienen un premio por hacer
algo diferente por ayudar a los demás
aita tenemos ya siete programas que
hicieron estos alumnos que van desde
ecología desde buscar que los niños en
las escuelas no se salgan tenían 60 por
ciento de niños de 6º de primaria que se
salían a medio año entonces van buscando
por el otro es colector de agua otro
inventado como
usar las cinco eres para toda la
compañía entonces te gustó tanto en la
en la escuela que el director ya lo hizo
con una materia de la escuela esas cinco
euros en sí siguió creciendo poco a
poquito
quiero terminar con una frase que tenía
en europa
siempre lo platicaba a todos nosotros
como hijos y a los empleados y nos decía
hagas lo que hagas
hazlo siempre lo mejor que puedas
y eso siempre nos dio mucho mucho éxito
en la compañía y además la comunidad los
clientes nos han apoyado mucho
y estamos muy agradecidos con eso con
dios con las familias y con todos los
empleados otra vez
[Aplausos]
[Música]